OPTION.
SEIZE IMAGINE YOU'RE A
SUCCESSFUL PUBLIC FIGURE.
AGE OF 5, YOU HIT A MID-LIFE
CRISIS, SO SEVERE, YOU DECIDE TO
LEAVE YOUR WIFE AND FOUR KIDS
FOR ANOTHER WOMAN.
YOU GET SO CARRIED AWAY WITH
YOUR NEW MISSTRESS AND YOU TEXT
HER PICTURES OF YOUR GENITALS
AND THOSE PICTURES END UP IN A
TABLOID.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
DOES THE MEDIA ATTACK YOU AS A
PATHETIC OLD CREEP OR DO
JOURNALISTS, INSTEAD, RALLY TO
YOUR DEFENSE?
WELL, THAT ALL DEPENDS ON HOW
RICH YOU ARE.
LUCKILY, JEFF BEZOSSOSIS IS VERY
RICH.
THE RICHEST MAN IN THE WORLD.
WHEN YOU'RE AS ITCH AS JEFF
BEZOSES  ON, THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS BAD PRESS COVERAGE.
BOB WOODWARD IS THE MOST FAMOUS
JOURNALIST IN AMERICA.
HE ONCE TOOK DOWN A PRESIDENT
WITH THE UNSPARING TOUGHNESS OF
HIS REPORTING.
HERE'S WHAT BOB WOODWARD WROTE
TO JEFF BEZOSES  ON, AFTER HIS
CROACH SHOTS BECAME PUBLIC.
JEFF, PROUD OF YOU FOR STEPPING
FORWARD IN SUCH A DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
VERY GUTSY AND DEFINITELY RIGHT.
THIS PERIOD REMINDS ME OF 1972
TO 1974.
PERHAPS WATERGATE REDUCKS.
SO MANY ASSAULTS ON
CONSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT.
LET'S HOPE WE ALL GET IT RIGHT.
AGGRESSIVE, BUT CAREFUL AND
FAIR.
CHEERS AND BEST.
BOB WOODWARD.
IF YOU CRITICIZE JEFF BEZOSES
ON, YOU'RE LIKE RICHARD NIXON
DURING WATERGATE.
AN ASSAULT ON OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
GOVERNMENT.
YOU'RE UNAMERICAN, IN FACT.
BOONE WROTE A COLUMN, DEFENDING
THE SELFIES.
THE HAD THE LINE WAS "JEFF
BEZOSES  ON STANDS HIS GROUND."
STANDS HIS GROUND, LIKE JOSHUA
CHAMBERLAIN.
THERE ARE GRANDCHILDREN THAT
REVERE HIS MEMORY AND SPEAK HIS
NAME.
BUT NO ONE WENT FURTHER THAN NEW
YORK TIMES TECHNOLOGY COLUMNIST,
KARA SWITCHER,
KARA SWITCHER -- IF FLATTERING
THE POWERFUL WAS AN OLYMPIC
EVENT, KARA SWISHIER WOULD BE
MARK SPITZ.
ADMIRABLE.
QUOTE, RELIC MOMENT, FROM QUOTE,
THE MOST IMPORTANT VISIONARY
SINCE STEVE JOBS.
IT GOES ON LIKE THIS
PORNOGRAPHICALLY AT ONE POINT,
THIS IS THE BEST.
SWISHIER SAYS, JEFF BEZOS OS'S
PRIVACY HAS BEEN VIBRATE
NATIONAL ENQUIRER, WHICH IS
TRUE.